ahora que los partidos independentistas
tienen las mayorías en el parlamento
escocés hablamos de los nacionalistas y
de los verdes cada vez más se abre el
camino político para un segundo
referendo de independencia del reino
unido- la ministra principal de escocia
nicola sturgeon
la jefa del scottish national party
quien ha liderado todo este proyecto de
un segundo referendo y quien fue
reelegida ayer también dijo que no
existe justificación democrática para
que londres se niegue a darle al pueblo
de escocia dice la oportunidad de este
segundo referendo y es que aunque
políticamente existe este camino todavía
hay que superar el obstáculo jurídico
dado que se requiere la aprobación del
parlamento británico y también del
primer ministro pero lo cierto es que
con estas mayorías es muy difícil
políticamente para boris johnson negarse
a esta segunda consulta la primera se
realizó en el 2014 y ganó la opción de
mantenerse dentro del reino unido- el
primer ministro
todos los integrantes de su gobierno han
dicho que este no es el momento político
para un segundo referendo el gobierno
escocés prevé realizar esta segunda
consulta cuando la pandemia del
coronavirus termine